the hogwarts castle model it's the best
model i've made this is the one that
stays in my mind harry potter and the
philosopher's stone has a set
combination of the massive warner
brothers studios and actual location
shoots not only did they utilize cgi
animation and tons of historical
landmarks but they also built their own
sets from the ground up
number one
also known as hogwarts the school of
witchcraft and wizardry this famous
castle that you can actually visit is
located in the english county of
northumberland they use this as a set
for the first and second films in the
harry potter franchise specific
locations in the castle like the outer
bailey the courtyards and the lions arch
were all very pertinent in the film
cinematography
number two
yes olmwit castle was used for a variety
of shots but the cool thing about harry
potter is that they used a combination
of practical sets cgi and animation to
give us the hogwarts we know and love a
team of 86 artists and crew members
created a mold of the hogwarts castle
that measures over 50 feet in diameter
and has over 2500 fiber optic lights
it was created for the sole purpose of
aerial photography and was digitally
scanned for the cgi scenes
number three the final challenge for
harry ron and hermione was a lot more
practical than you'd think every single
one of those chess pieces was sculptured
with fiberglass and steel by the art
department these chess pieces were so
large and had such presence they were
really very impressive to see
the king was over 10 feet tall the
pieces were remote controlled so they
did actually move across the board
even those explosions were real
number four
home of some great feasts
for the first day anyway the food in the
great hall was 100 real and the cast was
encouraged to eat the food
but unfortunately it did end up sitting
out and rotting for up to four days you
wound up smelling the great hall before
you even stepped inside
another thing the cast and crew
struggled with was the floating candles
they might look incredible but they
proved to be a bit of a dangerous hassle
not only did the crew have to light them
and lift them up on wires before each
scene
but they also had to have a fire
extinguisher on hand at all times daniel
radcliff recounts the experience and the
harry potter 20th anniversary returned
to hogwarts one of my favorite moments
on set ever was the moment when all the
floating candles started burning through
the ropes that tied them to the ceiling
and just started falling around the
great hall
number five
the iconic spot where harry learns he
can talk to snakes specifically the
reptile house in the london zoo located
in regents park london opened in 1927
the reptile house holds boaz cobras
crocodiles rattlesnakes chameleons and
iguanas instead of the python that harry
set free the real enclosure houses a
black mamba
number six
who wouldn't want to visit this place
leiden hall market is located in london
and it was used as exterior shots for
diagon alley most notably as the
entrance to the leaky cauldron though
its beautiful victorian exterior was
built in 1881 the market itself dates
all the way back to 1321. it was
originally a meat poultry and game
market but now it serves as a modern
shopping center full of boutiques
restaurants and cafes
this historical location which started
at the site of a manor has undergone an
immense amount of changes partially due
to what's known as the great fire but it
still remains a popular destination for
locals and tourists alike number 7.
king's cross holds a special place in jk
rowling's heart not only is that where
harry potter begins his journey in
wizardry
but it's also where her parents met
she says the station is evocative and
symbolic for her though the filmmakers
utilized the interior for scenes in
harry potter they actually used saint
patrick's station for the exterior shots
king's cross was built in 1852 they
found the terracotta design outside of
saint pancras to be a bit easier on the
eyes
number eight more specifically duke
humphreys library
this is part of the budlian library in
oxford and is only accessible through a
private tour this is home to the scene
where harry walks through the hogwarts
library with his invisibility cloak on
with the intention to steal a book from
the restricted stacks
number nine
bought out by warner brothers leaves in
studios home of all of the harry potter
movies spent millions on a harry potter
attraction site for fans to visit
because the books were still being
written during the production of harry
potter and the philosopher's stone they
made sure to keep every prop and set
piece in pristine condition so the fans
could see everything up close
leaves in studios is one of the largest
and most state-of-the-art filmmaking
facilities in the entire world home to
major films like the dark knight star
wars the hobbit and many many more
number 10
christ church holds a lot of very
important history not only in the harry
potter world though the historical
college was named by king henry viii and
was later used as a royal base during
the english civil war the christ church
great hall was the inspiration behind
the hogwarts dining hall
you'll notice the vast amount of
similarities between the two the bodily
staircase leading up to christ church
hall is used when hogwarts first years
walk up the stairs and are greeted by
professor mcgonagall
number eleven
the only practical thing about the
quidditch scenes were the broomsticks
everything else was achieved with a rig
and a green screen we'll program the rig
with our animation data so it looks like
the actor is steering the room and he's
riding around they would shoot each
character individually with the
appropriate lighting and camera angles
and then add the background and scenery
in post takes one two and three they
love it takes four and five
they're getting a little bit tired and
their bottoms probably a bit according
to the actors they did end up leaving
every time with a majorly sore butt
number 12.
yes it's an actual train properly known
as the jacobite steam express it's a
steam train located in glenfin and
viaduct scotland not only is it an
actual form of travel
but you can get on it and follow the
same journey that harry and all the
other hogwarts students did during the
film
number thirteen
not a place we were very fond of but an
actual suburban home nonetheless in the
later movies they ended up building a
set for four privet drive but before
they had the budget to do that they used
the house on 12 picket clothes in
bracknell the house was purchased a few
years ago and it's safe to say that the
owners definitely made a profit number
14 also known as hogsmeade station it
seems like there are quite a few iconic
train stations in the philosopher's
stone
this one holds two major scenes in the
film the first one is when the first
year students step off the hogwarts
express for the first time and the
second one when hagrid waves goodbye to
harry and the others at the end number
15.
also known as gringotts bank the only
bank in the wizarding world opened by
king george v in 1918 and built with
imported materials from australia hence
it's on the nose name this building is a
major landmark in real life
but for the potterheads it holds a
special place
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
is full of beautiful practical sets
historical landmarks churches and actual
suburban homes we've basically compiled
a list of places for every potter head
to visit what would be your first stop
you